hello folks how are you
i want to thank the business leaders for
joining us today as well as members of
my cabinet and the white house team
before getting
an update from my supply chain task
force
i want to say a word about the progress
our economy has made this year
and how my administration will continue
to tackle the cost increase
that american people are facing
in the end of 2021 with what one analyst
described as the strongest first year
economic track record of any president
in the last 50 years nearly 6 million
new jobs
a record number for a new president
because of my staff and my cabinet
unemployment down to 4.2 percent
three years ahead of the predicted time
it would take to get to that number
applicants for new small businesses up
30
compared to before the pandemic
and the fastest economic growth in
nearly 40 years
there's more as well
today america is the only leading
economy in the world where household
incomes and
for the pandemic
even accounting for price increases
the economy i inherited nearly a year
ago wasn't just in crisis
it wasn't working for working people i
told you that's the reason i ran it's
about time the middle class and working
class people got a shot
year after year economic growth was too
low
wages for the middle class were stagnant
and the number of people starting new
small businesses was declining
over this year we've acted from the
american rescue plan to the bipartisan
infrastructure law to change this
trajectory
to build an economy from the bottom up
in the middle out
and to finally give and by the way when
that occurs wealthy people do very very
well we're not trying to punish anybody
they do very well
working people in this country the wages
and benefits they deserve is about time
it starts they start to see it
to create an economy with more
innovation and faster growth
and we're making progress we got a way
to go we're making progress
still top of mind for me
is what is top of mind for so many
families
the uh the pinch of prices and the cost
look
addressing these costs has been and will
continue to be my top priority the
entire administration
and the way to do this is not to slow
down our economic turnaround not to step
back from this all this progress but to
build on it
we can and we will address prices by
expanding productivity capacity in our
economy so we move more goods to market
get more americans working encouraging
more investments in innovation and
making sure american consumers see those
benefits at the store and at the pump
when they go to fill up their cars
let me describe three specific areas i'm
focusing on
first
supply chains and i owe a lot to the
people of the business people on this
call on this zoom
earlier this fall
we heard a lot of dire warnings about
supply chain problems leading to a
crisis around the holidays
so we acted
a lot of recommendations of the people
that you see on the screen here i wish
we were all able to do this in person
we brought together business and labor
leaders to solve problems and much
you know the much predicted crisis
didn't occur
packages are moving
gifts are being delivered
shelves are not empty
experts in this field look at two
statistics for retail inventories
which is how many goods retail how many
good retailers have on hand and on a
phrase on shelf availability
which measures how many goods are
actually on the shelves there to be
purchased today retail inventories are
up three percent from last year
inventories are healthy and on shelf
availability before the pandemic was
about 91
today it's at 90 percent 90
i'm sure you can go and find some shelf
where it's empty because a particular
sort of gifts are very popular i don't
know but 90
availability
and delivery times of this season for
fedex ups and the u.s postal service are
faster than before the pandemic even as
americans have purchased a record amount
of goods
this in part due to the progress we've
made at our nation's ports
which are now moving historic amounts of
goods
you know after working with our
administration the ports of los angeles
and long beach have nearly cut in half
the number of those great big containers
you see
sitting on a dock for more than eight
days this is striking progress since
november
in fact right now the number of
containers moving through our ports
is higher than ever
it's because we've sped up a week
because when i sat down and talked with
the folks running the ports and the
longshoremen they agreed to speed up
every step in the process
the ports
the trains the trucking
my bipartisan infrastructure law
there's 17 billion dollars to speed up
and modernize our ports
and tomorrow the department of
transportation is going to announce over
200 million dollars in grants to ports
nationwide and we're making significant
investment in freight rail as well
and we're also working to unstick
bottlenecks
between the ports and the stores by
getting more trucks moving all around
the country
we've heard a lot about the need for
more truck drivers and it's real
and we've gotten to work to address that
for example
i want to i see marty walsh my labor
secretary marty have done a hell of a
job pal
cutting the red tape so that companies
can set up registered apprenticeships
for truck drivers in two days
instead of two months which it was
before you took over
these apprenticeships are going to help
new drivers get trained better and
faster and help companies retain drivers
in a field that has a lot has a lot of
turnover
so i'm eager to hear about the new
partnerships of trucking companies and
states to get more truckers on the road
and into good paying jobs
we also need to build resilience into
our supply chains
we can never again be left vulnerable
the way we were in the early days of
covet 19.
one important way to do this
is to make more things here in america
that has been a goal of mine since day
one of my administration
we've added more than 300 000 u.s
manufacturing jobs more than 300 000
added since i took office in january
20th
and we're going to keep at it because
the more the more of what we buy in
america
should be also made in america
the second area protecting american
consumers
take gas prices
months ago i saw oil production wasn't
keeping up with the demand as the world
started to get moving again
which could drive up prices
at the expense of our consumers
that's why i work with international
partners
to coordinate the release of oil from
our oil reserves and theirs now
gas prices are coming down
more than 10 cents a gallon nationally
gas prices in 21 states now
are at the historic averages before the
pandemic historic averages
that's good news for americans hitting
the road this week
but beyond energy we need to make sure
that there's a robust competition across
industries
competing is what encourages companies
to innovate encourage them to invest to
build
and offer lower prices
i'm going to be convening my competition
council earlier next year after in
january
to keep pushing for more bold action
because healthy competition is a
hallmark of healthy capitalism
thirdly
i'm working to reduce the largest cost
burden in households and budgets
and the biggest weapon
excuse it in our arsenal
it's my build back better act
which will reduce what families have to
pay for prescription drugs
for health care for child care
and so much more
the bill is paid fully
fully paid for
it won't increase the deficit
and nobody making less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year will pay a penny
more in federal taxes
top economic forecasters from wall
street firms reinforce just this week
that failing to act on the buildback
better plan will mean less economic
growth issue let me say it again
not a liberal think tank
wall street
failing to make these investments is
going to slow growth not increase it
look
if uh
if we in fact seize this opportunity
i think we can lower costs for families
getting more people working
and lower price pressures long term
and we're going to keep working on all
these fronts
because it is so clearly what american
families need right now
i'm going to now turn this over as much
more to say but maybe i've already said
too much i want to have an interchange
with you guys
but now i want to turn it over to brian
deese uh to begin this meeting we'll
move with i might have some questions in
fairness
great thank you mr president and we will
move immediately into the first section
of the of the agenda to focus on ports
and logistics the progress made uh and
additional steps to go forward and we'll
i hear from john porcari uh fred smith
uh and chris connor and then uh and then
turn the floor for some questions so
john over to you thank you brian mr
president we're making real and
sustained progress uh at the ports
there's increased uh fluidity and
velocity in the goods movement as you
reported
los angeles and long beach which
together are 40 of the imports to
america are moving record volumes of
goods
and the percentage of the the the number
of long dwelling containers the ones
that have been there eight days or more
has been cut in half
at the port of long beach since
mid-october the dwell times uh for those
containers has dropped from 12 days to
five days that's 140 improvement
and in los angeles from nine days to
four days 125 improvement
we are holding monday wednesday friday
morning action group meetings uh with
leadership of the ports with labor
the ocean carriers terminal operators
railroads and truckers to work through
problems in real time and talk to each
other through these problems
we're moving towards 24 7 operations at
the ports one of the ocean carriers cma
cgm
has opened their gates 24 7 at their
marine terminal and
put an incentive of 100
per container uh for moving the uh
containers that have been there zero to
eight days and two hundred dollars uh to
do it nights and weekends
uh the two
that the port on a truck or train or had
no warehouse or something that the idea
that's exactly right sir that's to
increase the velocity of the containers
uh uh and move them as quickly as they
hit the docks okay the two railroads
bnsf and union pacific have put
incentives uh on those moves as well in
pier pass which is the fee on truckers
uh uh using the ports has been waived
nights and weekends to increase 24 7
operations as well
innovations around the country include
the port of savannah the georgia ports
authority uh with federal help has put
together a number of pop-up sites inland
in some cases hundreds of miles inland
from the port to move by rail and then
truck uh both imports and exports and
about 500 000 containers a year will
ultimately be moved that way
so together these innovations and hard
work have really increased the fluidity
and velocity at the ports they've helped
activate increased activity all along
the goods movement chain
and the net result is the shelves are
stocked
packages are on porches
well thank you thanks for the great job
you're doing for me i really mean it
thanks for joining us great and uh we'll
just turn to uh fred uh smith now fred
who's been
been an integral partner uh in helping
us identify bottlenecks and ideas but
more importantly in executing and moving
more packages uh in this period than
than ever so give us your assessment if
you could fred and uh and uh thoughts
about uh things we need to focus on
going forward you've moved a few
packages in your day haven't you
we have mr president
thank you for having me and let me uh
thank you
john poncary and his task force uh
opening up the upstream parts of the
supply chain the head of fedex logistics
has
worked closely with him and and they've
just done a great job getting these
empty containers
off the ports and more chassis available
to move things inland
on the downstream side of the house of
course we're heavily involved there with
our fedex ground and fedex
express folks and i'd like to commend
our 600 000
plus team members for
delivering all sorts of things probably
most importantly the role we played on
distributing these vaccines to
get the pandemic behind us
some statistics i think that might be
helpful to you mr president
the first weekend of the peak season
after thanksgiving we moved 100 million
uh packages and we were able to do that
because
yes sir
and we were able to do that because uh
in
2021 we had had an aggressive expansion
program underway major investments
we added
14.4 million
square feet which is the equivalent of
about
300 football fields of sortation
capacity
24 major expansions and i might add
that uh
about half a dozen of those came on just
in the nick of time in november to make
sure the
supply chains were moving and i think
this is
also true of of ups and the postal
service have done a good job in
opening up capacity
uh the biggest issue that we experienced
over uh the summer
uh was lack of of
labor and the for sortation
to a lesser degree on the delivery side
to give you one statistic which will
illustrate that point we processed
approximately 52 000
employment applications online of course
these days in may may the 8th that week
uh over the last few weeks we've
exceeded 111 000
applications
so that's beginning to open up the
supply chain and uh there's still
pockets
uh there's several articles in the in
the business press today
in that regard
just in the last quarter working around
those
isolated pockets cost us about 240
million dollars so getting to your point
on
inflation as those begin to smooth out
i think you'll see less pressure on
on pricing in certain product uh
categories
so um the the supply chain issues are
not all solved but there's a lot of
effort underway to solve them and we're
optimistic that people will have a good
peak season and
uh most of uh santa claus's
uh
products will be delivered to the
consumers and the retailers have done a
great job of as you mentioned stocking
their shelves and many of them of our
great customers too so we we're happy to
take stuff into stores into businesses
vaccines into hospitals and e-commerce
packages to people's homes so we think
the peak season is going to be a good
one
i thought you were santa claus you're
doing a hell of a job
you got a big sleigh
thank you
thank you fred um uh uh chris uh
can you give us a perspective um from
the uh from the the ports nationally um
what you're seeing where the pockets of
event of innovation are and what we need
to be focusing on going forward
sure brian thank you very much mr
president and members of the supply
chain disruption task force thanks for
this opportunity to speak with you this
morning
um i'll just hit on you know the
headlines and some of these have already
been alluded to but i think the big
headline here is freight movement um off
of ports is improving and that's
happening due to extraordinary efforts
collaborative efforts between all supply
chain participants
coupled with creative solutions which
are easing congestion
despite all reports to the contrary over
several months
it is going to be a good holiday season
witness the national retail federation
on monday published an article where
they they say they believe that 2021
will be quote unquote the best holiday
season ever with holiday sales
rising 11 and a half percent above 2020.
we know a lot of those holiday sales
come from imported goods overseas so i
think what that tells us sir is despite
despite the systemic flaws that are
still there and we still have a battle
ahead of us there's been some
unbelievable human efforts and
collaboration happening
so mr president the dominoes are
beginning to move in the right direction
but i want to stress this is a
significant cultural
and operating model change so continued
focused and vigilant is an absolute
a few of the key lessons that we've
learned
the extended port and terminal hours of
operation
were needed and will continue to be
needed simply to keep pace
with the 24x7 operating models from some
of our primary trading partners
these extended hours had to start in the
u.s ports and now need to spread as they
are beginning to spread across the
entire supply chain
another lesson learned would be that
incentives even incentives that don't
actually get put in place like the
levees for dwelling containers
they work
john also alluded to other types of
incentives that ocean carriers and
raiders are putting in place these have
definitely contributed to the easing up
off-port property like the pop-up
container yards are a crucial element in
accelerating freight movement secretary
pete i believe you saw that firsthand
last friday down in savannah the four
yards that the georgia ports authority
has put in place
this is just smart business and will
allow us to move more freight through
that footprint
finally looking ahead and a few comments
on the um
iija which was signed into law on
november 15th
as the president mentioned this includes
significant funding for ports and is
sorely needed and is a crucial step in
repositioning america's competitive
posture in global trade the port
industry looks forward to working with
dot and marad to submit grant
applications
for this next round this plus up round
into course to secure grant funding for
resiliency and intermodal connectivity
improvements at ports small and large
across the country
sustained federal investment in port
infrastructure will spur
public private partnerships which will
further strengthen our nation's
competitiveness
and finally we're pretty excited about
the um the mandate in iaga which calls
for the establishment of the office of
multimodal freight infrastructure and we
look forward to working with that office
and it's serving uh as a strategic nine
non-partisan and geographically agnostic
body to help develop smart and
actionable direction and policy
recommendations for the future mr
president thank you again for this
opportunity chris i want to emphasize if
i may
um
we get through this season
that's that's good stuff lots going on
but i really
one of the reasons i insisted there'd be
so much billions of dollars in the four
ports in the infrastructure plan
is i i want this to be
universal
you know i i don't want this just just
focus just on the big ports there's a
lot we can do as you know and i'm
anxious to literally i mean and
sincerely sit down with you
and your colleagues and come up with the
game plan some of what you outlined here
as to how to get this done
and pete is ready to do it i mean we're
ready to move on this and so because i
think we can not only you know that old
expression make make lemonade out of
lemons i think we got a shot here to
come out of this whole crisis not only
you know that phrase build back better
but to literally be in a better
circumstance next year than we were
before the credit before the crisis hit
i mean i i think and anyway we should be
leading the world and i think we can
but thank you thank you sir
thank you mr president
we're going to pause quickly and give
the uh press an opportunity to uh depart
and then we're going to turn to a next
section of our meeting on uh on uh
inventories and trucking
yes i did
hello if you want to talk to me about
what's on here you can ask me a question
one of the things wait wait wait wait
wait a minute i asked the first question
did i get my test today yes i did before
i walked in here
okay
and i haven't gotten the result yet
i guess i walked over
i say no
thank you
okay
okay all right all right
uh
um we're gonna turn now to uh uh
uh to uh sergey singal uh at gap
and sonia